[Music]
hi I'm Alex vice Burt I am a software
engineer at Google I work on machine
learning models for Google ads and
before that I was a quant and portfolio
manager for a number of years at some of
the largest hedge funds and hi welcome
I'm Mike Stone I'm a global technology
director at Thomson Reuters I work with
some of our largest global clients and
focus on helping them advance their
innovation and technology strategies I'm
excited to be here with Alex's we're
going to explain how you can leverage
the Google platform capabilities along
with using Thomson Reuters data start us
off Alex okay so Oh building and
training a stock price forecasting model
in Google cloud is a very cool exciting
project yes yet it is also a challenging
project because you need to figure out
not just how use each of those
high-powered leading-edge tools the
Google cloud provides you also need to
understand and figure out how to put all
those pieces together how to build your
complete data processing pipeline and to
amp and this is exactly the goal of this
session to show you how to do just that
and their idea is that after this
session you will be able to build and
train your own model in Google cloud and
it will seem easy for you so this
session is going to be a very practical
very hands-on with lots of code snippets
as well as high-level diagrams and
discussions so what exactly does it mean
to build and train a stock price
forecasting model in the cloud what does
it entail there are three components
first of all market data is supposed to
be in the cloud what does it mean it
means that the data is hosted in the
cloud
and is available to you the native cloud
api's second what does it mean to do
data processing in the cloud it means
that you're using tools and services
that are also native to the cloud and
all your data processing pipeline end to
end is native to the cloud and finally
what it mean to train your model in the
cloud it means that you're using cloud
services to train your mouth ma to train
your model as a distributed application
with multiple jobs running concurrently
and training your model at much higher
scale potentially and much faster so
market data is key to models this is
what powers financial models and this is
what brings them to life and one of the
key leading financial market data
companies is Google cloud strategic
partner Thomson Reuters and with this
I'm turning it over to Mike thanks Alex
what I like to do over the next several
minutes is just give you a quick
overview of the journey Thomson Reuters
is taking in terms of bringing our
datasets to the cloud specifically what
we're doing with Google and then give
you a quick overview of the actual data
asset alex is going to be using for the
stock forecasting model now as Alex
mentioned market data certainly powers
financial models when you want to run
those Thomson Reuters itself our data
and solutions power the financial
services industry our data for those of
you who aren't aware of who Thomson
Reuters is is used by ten of the top 10
global banks ninety 90 percent of all
companies managing over ten billion
dollars use our solutions and
eighty-seven percent of the
institutional investors top global
research firms also use our data now let
me give you some insight where and how
our data is actually used
now Thomson Reuters is an open platform
that's cloud enabled we call it it's
branded as electron data platform and
basically what it does is it serves the
major functions of an institutional firm
around the globe let me highlight a few
of those the divisions the Investment
Banking sales and trading wealth
management division commercial banking
retail banking risk and regulatory to
name a few of them now the electron data
platform itself is a set of services
analytics
integration tools and then ultimately
content and content is really the
foundation of the platform itself if I
take a look I'm sure this is an eye
chart for those of you at the back but
what it represents is one of the most
extensive data set Thomson Reuters has
in the industry it spans all the way
from the award-winning and leading
Reuters news and commentary which is
available not only as human readable
text but also as machine readable
real-time feeds then it spans through
market data pricing security reference
data risk and regulatory a very wide
range of company data and then wrapping
up risk compliance and supply chain data
now it's one thing to have all the data
though how do we make that available to
our clients as I mentioned previously we
have the electron data platform which
again it's our journey that we're moving
that towards the cloud now most of the
data within the financial service
industry functions in a cycle and let me
use an example to explain what that
psychologically actually represents with
real-time data if we were to look at
what we collect from exchanges over 500
them globally around the world we take
all the security activity from the
exchange we bring it in normalize it
enhance it and then tag it with common
identifiers from there it's now ready
for distribution for to our clients
either through a suite of our own api's
or as we progress making it more and
more available through the cloud itself
let me give you some insight on the
strategy Thomson Reuters is taking as we
go to the cloud there's three primary
pillars to our strategy for our own
internal systems it's cloud first so
everything we're doing we're building in
the cloud secondarily where it's more
important how do we get our data out to
our clients we're evolving with the
industry and providing that data through
various methods as I mentioned native
cloud services we'll talk more about
Google bigquery later or through our own
suite of api's available in the cloud
already the last area is transforming
our own previously deployed systems and
making those as a service in the cloud
where basically again we pulled them out
and have a zero footprint in our clients
now let's look a little more
specifically at that from recent surveys
from our clients they've given this
perspective on how they're moving their
applications to the cloud
I found the right hand-side for
financial institutions it's basically
the trade lifecycle all the way from pre
trade trade post trade middle office
activities compliance and then
ultimately the back office technology
wraps things up across the top what
we've got is we're charting between what
clients have done today and what they
expect to do in the future in terms of
prioritization and moving to the cloud
and across the bottom it matches nicely
with the type of data either relatively
static historical data right now all the
way through to the future we're
real-time transactional services will be
required and what we've plotted out is
what clients have told us they've been
deploying to the cloud already and
there's a few general things that we can
observe from this one is the
applications are across the entire trade
lifecycle so no one shine away from
deploying applications anywhere within
their business and then ultimately to a
lot of its being used for analytics and
reporting type capability out in the
future clients expect that there's some
things that still need to be worked out
to really get truly low latency data in
the cloud and it'll prove out over time
if that's a valid use case or not for
example for algo trading finally to
summarize things a lot of the data right
now is relatively high volume data and
therefore is used very efficiently by
cloud services which brings us to tick
history data one of the largest data
sets within the financial services
industry is tick data tick data for
those of you not familiar is really the
collection and storage of all trade
activity bid and ask prices and
everything for security in the market so
we collect that up and as mentioned
before that's part of what we process
through our EDP platform now back in
1918 you see how they worked aboard to
store that information certainly there's
been a lot of evolution in that data
since then I don't think these two
working the board could keep up with
today's volumes or necessarily worried
about nanosecond time stamps
specifically now what clients can do
today in accessing Thomson Reuters take
history data in the cloud is they can
take it through our Web Services API or
as a proof of concept right now as we
sort out the most efficient methods
we've actually loaded a few years of the
20 years history of the New York Stock
Exchange data right into the bigquery
tables it's very efficient for using
training models and doing simulations on
that volume of data
it's one of the ways you can access over
the 20 years of history of
market-leading quality of the foreign
exchanges we've collected it from and
then ultimately to when I talked about
enriching data here's a perfect example
we've taken all the corporate actions
whether it be splits or dividends and
that's already incorporated for you
and then ultimately to if you're linking
it with other data it comes in the same
format with the same set of identifiers
you've already used a few other benefits
you don't have to worry about by
managing in the cloud you don't have to
worry about collecting the data and
managing that infrastructure you're not
going to worry about the database CPUs
and servers and managing them and then
ultimately for disaster recovery and
backups also part of the built-in
services of the cloud now to go
specifically what did we actually put in
so I said as a proof of concept at this
point we've worked with a number of
clients we've taken three years or so of
the New York Stock Exchange data we've
put it in a table it represents the
trade and quote data that goes on so for
example we've got an identifier which is
the RIC or the Reuters instrument code
we have a number of other fields in
terms of the time the bid the price
ultimately the trade data includes
similar information if we want to get
access to it it's as simple as a sequel
query we just list the fields the date
the fields of the table we want to pull
it from in this case we're pulling GS 10
which is Goldman Sachs from the NIH's E
and then we say we want the quote data
voila
this is what we're gonna get back very
quickly if we want to do similar for
trade data just a slightly different
query we're gonna modify the fields say
that we want to pull trade data and
here's what we've got this is the data
that alex is going to be using to
explain the model so I'm going to pass
it back to him now so he can explain how
he's leveraged Thompson Reuters data
along with the Google cloud capacity so
that you can make it easier for yourself
thank you Mike it was great
ok data processing pipeline now the fun
begins we're going to take a look at how
to put together the data processing
pipeline and before we get into nitty
gritty details I'll give you a
high-level overview what we're going to
be doing so the first step is we're
going to generate model features
starting from the Thomson Reuters data
in bigquery and this can be done
from a Python script or from a collab in
case you don't know collab is an
extremely useful tool built by Google
it's a hosted Python notebook it's
hosted the Google cloud it's a free
service when you use it you get access
to cloud services and you even get a
free GPU on the cloud you don't have to
pay for it and in collabnet books you
can write your code you can execute your
code and you can see the output all
within one notebook and it's very
convenient for sharing with your
teammates for example ok second step in
the data pipeline is we're going to
write model input features into what is
called CF record files so this is the
standard format for representing input
features data for tensorflow models the
third step is we're going to launch
model training using using cloud ml
engine when the training job starts the
workers will be loading model features
from Tenzer for tensorflow record files
that have been previously written the
Google Cloud storage and periodically
the worker jobs will be saving model
state checkpoints as well as training
and evaluation statistics in a bucket in
cloud storage so that's the pipeline now
let's take a look at model predictions
how what we're going to be predictable I
start with that what metric will the
model before casting when we're talking
about stock price forecasts the model
the key is to define what horizon were
talking about are we going to be
forecasting for a year for several
months days so to be specific for this
example that we're going to show you
we're going to be forecasting intraday
stock returns with five minute horizon
the reason we chose this for this
examples because this is something
useful practical it's useful for
scheduling suborders for algorithmic
execution orders execution August and
it's useful for intraday trading
strategies so it's something relevant
now let's take a big-picture view for a
moment and
the discuss a little bit what exactly
we're going to be doing here we're going
to be using supervised learning meaning
that we're going to be training our
model on examples each training example
is a pair comprising input features and
the correct answer so input features are
whatever inputs the model is going to be
using to give us their prediction and
the label is the correct answer so given
inputs and correct answers the model
will be learning and learning until it
hopefully is able to generate correct or
more or less correct predictions even
when it doesn't know what they're going
to be based on the inputs okay so what
are going to be our labels how do we
construct the labels predictions so our
goal is to predict intraday returns for
five minutes arisin and for this we need
to define the starting price and the
final price the end price for the
starting price we're going to be using
the average banais midpoint for the
current 10-second interval and for the
final price we're going to be using
five-minute volume weighted average
price or div up for the 5-minute
interval subsequent to the current point
and time and then it's actually relevant
because when you schedule sub orders you
want to know what will be the V Bob not
just some price at some random point in
time but V what may be more relevant
here so this is the picture that
illustrates what exactly we're doing we
are calculating the average midpoint
were calculating the V before the next
5-minute interval and the we take the
logarithm of those two values and the
difference of logarithms is the label
that we're going to be using for
training the model so after we're done
with building and training the model
we're going to be taking a look at
evaluation statistics to see how well
the model performs but I guess you're
already curious to see how it performs
and so we're going to have dessert first
before we're done with the main entry
okay so this is what we did for this
example we trained the model on 16 days
so turns on Rory's market data between
May 1st and 24th
and we evaluated model on one day Oh
market data May 25th so you can see that
devaluation data should always be after
the end of the training data don't want
to have any Luka heads here and we're
using our square as a measure of the
quality of the model what is R square
approximately it tells you how good is
the model compared to a trivial model
that always predicts the zero return so
for this particular example R square was
0.1 which means that the model was
useful if R squared zero it means the
model is as good or as bad as the
trivial model that always predicts zero
returns if R square is one it means the
model is perfect if it's between zero at
one it means it has some predictive
capability so here you can see that for
the zero prediction model the mean
squared error on evaluation data was 231
squared basis points where basis point
is 101 percent and the mean squared
error for the for our model on
evaluation it was 207 so it was slightly
better than the trivial model and this
is roughly what would be expected
because you do not realistically expect
to forecast all or even most of the
variance at five minute interval because
there is a lot of noise and intraday
prices okay so let's take a look at how
we build the inputs what are we going to
be fitting into the model we're going to
be defining input features based on what
types of factors that affect stock
returns we're trying to capture here
okay so first we're going to learn
intraday price patterns at different
times of the day and to do this we are
going to include a feature based on the
intraday sequence number over the
current 10-second interval then we want
to capture mean reversion or momentum
price patterns and for this we're going
to be using a list of differences server
logarithms of average midpoint quotes in
the last hundred twenty 10-second
interval so essentially what this means
this long sentence is
that were looking at returns between
consecutive 10-second intervals for the
trailing 20-minute window and we're
using this list as one of the input
features then we want to capture price
patterns for stocks at different price
levels and for this were looking at the
logarithm of the price at the at the
current 10-second interval then volume
is also relevant and so as one of the
input features were going to be using a
volume in the trailing 20-minute window
preceding the current interval but for
this to be useful want to normalize the
volume by the stock's average daily
volume over some reasonably long time
range and for this example we use for
week average daily volume as a
normalization factor so we take volume
tradable and for the stock in the last
20 minutes and we divide it by these
stocks average daily volume over the
past four weeks okay and finally we're
going to be using an input feature based
on their stocks security and then the
fire week because different stocks may
have their unique distinct intraday
price patterns and I will show you how
to plug in a three-course string in
general into the model okay now get
ready for some heavy construction work
ahead I'm going to start showing you
some more slides with the actual SQL
code snippets so first of all we're
going to be using bigquery what is
bigquery it's a Google cloud enterprise
data warehouse ideal for analytics you
can run standard sequel queries on it
and also it has some very useful
extensions analytic functions I will
show you how to use those functions it's
fully managed and serverless meaning
that Google takes care of provisioning
of CPU and storage capacity of data
application don't have to worry about
any of that
ok feature number one in today's
sequence number of the kernel second
interval so what we want to do here is
basically calculate the number of
seconds since midnight and divided by 10
and to do this we extract the hour x 360
we convert from UTC time and the local
time because
we care about stock patterns specific to
the exchanges local time no TVC time we
extract number of minutes multiplied by
six and we extract number of seconds
divided by ten and rounded up so this is
our interval sequence number okay
building block for feature number two
lists of ten second interval midpoints
so one nice thing bicker provides is the
ability to use temporary tables as a
part of your query so you can in this
example we use interval midpoints as a
temporary table you write a query and
the output of the query is stored in the
temporary table and then we can use this
table within from within another query
and here we're using array aggregation
function which is an analytic function
of bigquery that allows you to apply
certain function over a series of rows
preceding each row in the output so what
I want to do here is to partition data
by Rick and the the over Clause
specifies how exactly we're going we're
going to do it so partitioned data by
Rick buy stock identifier within each
partition where order rose by interval
sequence number and with this ordering
for each role we take 120 preceding rows
and make a list of them and return this
as the output of the query ok feature
number 3 normalized trade the volume so
there are three steps here as I
mentioned before we compute each stocks
average daily volume for the last four
weeks we compute interval volumes
normalize them by a DV and then for each
interval we compute the sum of
normalized volumes for for those
10-second intervals in the preceding
20-minute window so there are three
steps here and similarly as before we
use a temporary table to store average
daily volumes then we use this temporary
table from another query so
calculate Oh
interval valves normalized by a DV and
then we use those values from yet
another query in which we use analytic
function called sum which instead of
making a list of rows values from
preceding rows here it just adds up
values from a list of preceding rows and
just before we specify that we want to
help sir I wouldn't specify that we want
to partition data by Rik we want to
order rows in each partition by interval
sequence number and for each row we want
to apply the sum 420 preceding rows okay
now we're going we're going to show how
to construct building block for the
label live up in the five-minute period
subsequent to each interval this is
something that we won't have when we're
generating forecasts but this is
something that we're going to have when
training the model so once again we use
a temporary table for interval price
volumes we use this table from another
query which for each row for each
interval compute the sum of price
volumes and the device by the sum of
volumes okay now one thing that's very
convenient about using bigquery for data
and Google cloud is that it's very
nicely integrated with Python there is a
pandas package called IO gbq that has
this method called read gbq you can pass
the query you pass your project ID in
Google Cloud and it returns the output
of a query into a panda's data frame and
then you can do additional
transformations of data generation of
final features from our semi final
results of queries directly within
pandas data frames which have very rich
functionality so it's very convenient
now once we have this final data frame
with all features that you need you can
save it into a JSON file with the to
JSON function JSON format is very
convenient in in in that it preserves
the structure of data so for example it
will save lists as Lee
if you used to CBS function for example
it will save lists as strings and you
lose the structure so I recommend to
JSON and then finally if you wish you
can use gsutil tool but it's one of
their tools and Google Cloud to copy
your JSON file into one of the buckets
in the cloud okay generating T of record
files so it's your a kurd is the
recommended format for storing
sterilized mount features and tensorflow
so what we do we run queries in big
queries to get the data we'll put data
into data frames will apply this on
transformations and then we use those
data frames with everything prepared to
generate your record files and those
files will be later fed to the model for
training so the rest three steps here
generating training examples comprising
model input features serializing
training examples entity of record files
and feeding self record files into the
model so what is a training example it's
actually a Python dictionary or map it
Maps feature names to feature products
or protocol messages and there are three
types you can have a list of bytes
elitsa floats or a list of integers you
always have a list and what do I do with
the features that are scalars if it's
not at least you simply have a list with
one element in it
so there is an example there is how we
construct an example of assuming that
each role holds values for features from
our data frame that we have constructed
earlier so Delta logs live at me this is
what we're going to be using for our
label this is the correct answer that we
only have during training we don't have
it when we're actually doing using them
out to make predictions and we have five
features that I described earlier the
Rick stock identify interval sequence
number deltas of log meets sum of
interval volumes and logarithm of the
current meet okay how do you use these
to actually generate your record files
the first step is to initialize the
record writer
then you iterate over rows in the data
frame that contains your features and
for each role you construct an example
based on that feature dictionary that I
showed you on the previous slide then
you serialize this example and you write
it into the TF record writer finally
when you are done you're closing the
writer and you have this file with
sterilized CF records if you only intend
to train your model locally you can
generate this file in a local directory
but if you are planning to use cloud
thermal engine you have to copy this TF
records file into cloud storage so that
it can be accessed by multiple jobs
multiple tasks that are running as part
of the cloud ml engine job ok preparing
data to train the model so self records
can be efficiently fed into tensorflow
model for training and evaluation and in
the next several slides we're going to
look at exactly how we're going to be
feeding those models to our model and
there are three steps here the first
step is we're going to define feature
columns and I will show it to you in a
moment in a moment what they are second
step we're going to create a parsing
spec and third step we're going to
define an input function that will use
their parsing spec okay step one
defining feature counts for the model so
feature counts is a list it specifies
the type of each feature so here for
example for the RIC we're using what's
called an embedding column we're
plugging stocks identifier a string as
an embedding which means essentially
that we're making the string into a
numeric value and this numeric value may
represent for example stocks propensity
to have mineral wording versus momentum
price patterns and 1kv that you need to
be aware of is when they use embeddings
you want to make sure that you set hedge
bucket size so large and available
because you certainly want to avoid
collisions in the hashmap use from
beddings as much as possible essentially
when you have collisions the model
doesn't distinguish between two
different rigs in this case and you
don't want to do that then you have
feature columns for other model inputs
in this case interval sequence number
some of interval volumes for the
trailing window and logarithm of the
current mean you can see that we specify
their shape the first dimension is 1 in
all cases meaning that they're they all
have with 1 they're all scalars and then
we have Delta log Meads which for which
we specify shape with the first
dimension set 120 or flight' in the fact
that it's expected to be a list of
hundreds and 20 values values okay step
two here is creating person spec and
this is very easy to do with the
function called make parse examples back
so you pass this list of feature
specifications to this function and
gives you features spec that we can use
in the input function which is the next
step we're going to define input
function the next couple of slides let's
see what we're doing here the first step
is constructing a data set and for this
I recommend using function called make
badge features data set it creates
already performance optimized data set
with batching and shuffling built in so
you don't need to worry about reading
your data efficiently don't need to
worry about setting up multiple threads
through it your data because sometimes
it's a bottleneck it does everything for
you so where previously you would make
several function calls here you can just
use this function so let's look at the
parameters here the file patron
specifies the list of files of TF record
files that you have generated previously
so for example you can have a separate
CF record files for market data from
distinct trading days then a batch size
so here we say that 128 what this means
it means that
the training examples are going to be
passed to the model not one by one but
all together in batches and each batch
is going to have 128 training examples
when you feed training examples to the
model it generates predictions and the
loss is computed for the difference
between predictions and actual correct
answers and then based on the loss the
back propagation of gradients is applied
so when use a page the back propagation
happens only once with the entire page
all gradients are averaged over all
training examples of then there is back
propagation happening one so this is
called mini batching and usually it
improves model performance when you
train it with the base I set around
hundred to a thousand now the feature
spec is what we construct earlier number
of epochs is that the one is this simply
means that we are reading the data set
just once we can read it several times
if you wish shuffle is set to true what
this does it randomizes the order in
which it puts
training examples the treats from the
file in two batches it makes mono more
robust then we'll make an iterator so
make one-shot iterator it simply creates
an iterator that reads the data from the
data set just once there are other types
of iterator some of them breed data or
more than ones and this is interesting
the getnext function so it looks like if
you look at this function it returns you
returns features but in fact it does not
what this function returns is an
operation node in the computation graph
and then later on when this node is
evaluated it will return next batch of
examples every time it's evaluated and
this is a very important subtle point so
I have a separate slide just for this
because it's the key point to understand
tensorflow programs in batch mode run in
to fail in the in graph modes or in
graph mode they have two phases in phase
one you construct the computation graph
but no data is flowing
through the graph yet then in phase 2
you execute the computation within a
tensorflow session and this is when data
actually flows through the graph so in
our function data sitting will function
it edits edits implemented it doesn't
return any pages of data yet but instead
what it does it adds notes the complete
tensorflow computation graph and then
when later on the nodes are evaluated
within a session they will be returning
next batch of training examples upon
each evaluation so you see this so we're
back to dataset input function see their
turns features and labels so a features
is an operational in a tensor flow graph
and labels is another for each node in
terms of glow tensor flow graph ok
training the model first we are going to
look at how to train the model locally
so the model will be trading on examples
we feed it and with with some number of
examples on the widget trains hopefully
it will learn how to make correct
predictions that's the less house who
provides loading words so the first step
is to construct a DNN regressor
tensorflow has several built-in
estimators so general bresson DNN
regressor is one of the estimators and
it's intended for use with models that
make numerical predictions which is what
we're doing in our example Oh hidden
unit specifies the structure of the
neural network so here we are going to
be using two fully connected layers and
each layer is going to have 128 hidden
weights Oh feature columns so this is
exactly the feature counts that we
defined earlier it's a list of
specifications of the dimensionality and
type of each input feature and mono
direct sorry model directory is an
important argument that specifies where
the model is going to be saving its
burek check
point so it's state and where it's also
going to appear eclis saving its
training and evaluation statistics okay
so here I am again going over the
feature columns there is embedding
column for the Rick there is an American
for interval sequence number of shape
one some is Rivoli one low current meet
they all have with one and Delta log
means cat has with 120 okay and I
already said that more directories where
the model stores its checkpoints and
this is also importantly the directory
from which the model reads its state to
initialize when you construction and
regressor later on and by using this
feature you can train the model
iteratively or incrementally so the way
it works is initialized in an aggressor
from the latest checkpoint then a
trained model on newly available data
for example a newly available data set
and your checkpoints will be
automatically saved in the mounted
directors so it will create new
checkpoints with the files under new
file names and to automatically garbage
collect old checkpoints so for example
in case a financial data you can
incremental train the model at the end
of each training trading date so at the
end of the trading date you collect all
market data for this date you train the
model training examples for that date
the model starts with a checkpoint from
the previous date after it rains it
saves its state and a checkpoint
representing its state after it has
incremental e train to a market data
from today and then tomorrow can go on
okay so how do train them well one thing
before we get to training is you may
want to add some custom performance
metrics evaluation metrics but default
general Grasser has one metric it's we
chose el título spells which is mean
squared error and it may be useful to
have root mean square error as well so
this is how you add the custom
evaluation metrics
and okay Cyril almost at the point where
we're training the models before trying
them out we need to construct training
spec and evaluation spec and what does
Asus primarily specify input functions
so we can use the same input function
but simply initialize them differently
with the different lists of files we
pass the list of training files into the
train specification and we'll pass the
list of a list of evaluation files for
the eval specification and very
importantly with when training models
evaluation data should start after the
end of the training data don't want to
have any look Ahead's here and also the
board to specify the number of maximum
steps for training because the depending
on the how you implement your data set
input function if you don't specify this
your model may train forever it will
never stop okay and finally train and
evaluate functions the recommended way
of training tensorflow model that uses
dinner and regressor well it does it
trains the model it Pericles checkpoints
the state and it Pyrrhic elite
checkpoints training and evaluation
performance metrics all in the same
directory but there is a separate
subdirectory for evaluation metrics okay
now we look at how to train the model
locally now let's take a look at how you
will do it with the cloud ml engine so
why would you want to use cloud ml
engine the primary purpose is it gives
you scalability it gives you a bill to
train the model with multiple workers
multiple tasks at the same time this way
you can train your model many times
faster and you can have much faster
turnover over different verses of the
mouse you want to try you can do your
research much faster this way so the
good thing is when you transition your
model from local training through
training with chordoma engine you don't
need to change your code at all when
you're you
estimators they are already have
built-in support for cloud the mail
engine and that's extremely convenient
so all you have to do it's a specified
configuration file you need specify code
to construct reading package the setup
and you need to provide the main program
to train the mount which already have
because it's the same program so
configuration settings you need to
specifies their skills here in this
example we're going to be using a
customs here because it's the most
interesting most flexible you can
specify exactly the hardware
configuration of four different types of
nodes in your training job so let's take
a look at the different types of nodes
there are three types there are worker
nodes which calculate gradients
there are parameter and and workers are
the nodes that do lots of numerical
computations matrix multiplications and
they are the nodes that you will want to
run with GPUs to get faster performance
then there are parameters server nodes
which update parameters with gradient
vectors from workers enter and then
there is a master node which coordinates
everyone and also operates as a worker
so based on that based on the usage
we're going to be using standard GPU for
master and worker worker nodes and we're
going to be using certain CPU for
parameter servers and also get to
specify how many workers are how many
parameters service we want to use for
this example we're going to be trading
model with eight workers and four
parameter servers okay their code to
construct training package there is a
separate file you need to provide and
you specify the list of required
packages in many cases this list will be
actually empty because each cloud ml
engine runtime comes with the already
built in list of many popular Python
packages so if you are using something
that's very non-standard you may need to
specify it here in this pile in setup
button many case you won't need to and
the main program to train the mouse the
same
as for local training and again let's go
over what it does it parses command line
parameters it defines feature columns it
constructs then an agressor defines a
relation matrix if you need any it
defines the input function that we'll be
reading to your records from a list of
files and it will start training and
emulating the model so this is the
command you used to submit a job to
cloud ml engine you need to specify a
unique job name you specify the path to
your main program that does the training
this is the program that creates an
aggressor and cause train and evaluate
function you specify the path to your
configuration file you specify the path
of your staging bucket and in cloud
storage and then specify the runtime
version so this number in the runtime
version runtime version is exactly the
version of tensorflow
so depending on what version of
tensorflow you intend to use depending
on your code dependencies you will
specify the version here and as I said
each version each runtime version called
ml engine comes with the different list
of packages already built in the runtime
now then we need to specify the region
there are two regions support at the
moment your center one and US east one
and finally if you need to you can
specify a list of custom parameters that
will be passed to your training
application ok evaluation of the model
so what is evaluation the key question
you want to answer is how precise is our
model what's the quality of predictions
how well does it perform on evaluation
data so we're going to be using tensor
board for this this is how Iran attends
our board and you combine this
goaltender board and then you specify
the directory where model check points
are in tabulation statistics and
training statistics are safe this is the
same model directory that they use when
you construct it did an agressor object
okay so this is what l2 loss look like
on the training data that we'll use for
this model example this is what the law
look like for the first three and a half
hours of training you can see that it
started L too low started at around 90
probably and it was gradually decreasing
over the next two and a half hours
meaning that the model is the model
trains its lowest on training data
becomes gradual or and lower but this
doesn't necessarily mean that the model
is becoming better in its predictions
because what we really care about is
their quality of generalizations and
when we look at the l cellos for
iteration data we see that the model
starts around 206 after 30 minutes of
training and then actually you can see
that lost enumeration data increases
slightly to around 210 211 so what this
means is you probably may want to stop
training your model after first half an
hour because after that l2 loss on
training data it will keep decreasing
but this simply means that the mouth
gradually starts overfitting so you want
to stop training because you're not
going to improve quality of predictions
after that the longer it trade after
first half an hour in this example the
worst sexual the model prediction
evaluation data so there is usually an
optimal amount of training you want to
apply okay so I said this already and
let's take a look at the r-squared so as
I mentioned before square gives you an
idea of how well the model performs on
evaluation data compare it to a trivial
model that always predicts zero returns
and as I said if if the value is zero it
means the model is worthless if it's 1
it means the model is perfect and
usually we expect the value to be closer
to zero than to one but to be positive
and as it happens that's the case here
R square is approximately point 10 2.11
after first 20 to 30 minutes of training
and then it declines the range between
point oh eight and point oh nine which
is actually decent for when when you're
predicting five-minute prices intraday
prices but remember this was based on
model trained on only 16 days of market
data and evaluated on only one day of
data so this is
this is fine for an example of how to
build them on how to train it but this
is not what you would want to do in for
actual use in production for using
production training trading you would
want to train your mom on several years
of dating evaluate and throw years of
data okay during a generating forecast
once we have the model how do we
generate forecasts for training it's
convenient to save data into your record
files when you want to build the
forecast in real time it may actually be
more convenient to store data in data
frames in pandas dataframes memory than
to read from from files I will show how
to do it a bit later so the key is that
for generating predictions we use the
same initialization settings as when you
were training the model same same hidden
units same model directory same future
column so that's that's important as I
said we're going to be using pandas data
frame and when input functions bite on
upon us data frame each data frame so
each data frame row is going to include
feature values for one training example
and each column is going to have feature
values for one feature time feature type
and the input function is going to
return a dictionary mapping input
names have been put features to tensors
containing their features Bayliss for
the entire batch the essential values
for one column in the panda's data frame
so the future tense will be
two-dimensional the first dimension is
the size of the batch which is the
number of rows in data frame and second
dimension is the width of the
corresponding feature column so we have
Rick we have interval sequence number
sum of intro volumes log of the current
mid Delta log meet so you see here the
second dimensions con written 20 and
there is a little bit different
transformation here because first we
need to convert the list of recent numpy
multi-dimensional array
and then we shave the array is required
with a second dimension set 120 then we
use the predict method that returns
predictions generator we use I slice
method together iterator and here it's
important to specify the number of steps
in the iterator otherwise it may never
stop and then as we iterate we get this
list of predictions which correspond to
rows in the data frame so the length of
this list would exactly their length of
the data frame the number of rows so the
wrap-up what have we accomplished we
have we have shown how to build model
features using Thomson Reuters data in
Google cloud using bigquery we can look
at how to serialize input features into
F record files in cloud storage we have
seen how to construct and regressors and
build and train the models locally and
we have seen how to train the model as a
scalable distributed application using
cloud ml engine on with multiple workers
and now the hope that we invite you to
apply the knowledge that you have gained
in this session to try and build and
train your own machine learning model in
Google Cloud and put all pieces of your
own puzzles together into a beautiful
picture thank you
[Music]